[Musica]
berlino
hai sentito che tu
ti senti in giro
vitale vieni subito qui guarda
eni che si muove sono stato una folata
di vento o le finestre aperte di no no
non è stato il belgio si sente qualcuno
al piano di sopra specchi questo rumore
di pasti ma io non sento niente ma non
si sentono più sopra il piano di sopra
in cantina ma forse più che passi sono
dei passeri più cellini che camminano
sui tetti
no non sono dei pastori sono dei passi
c'è qualcosa o qualcuno al piano di
sopra
vero anche voi li avete sentiti vero i
nostri titoli e non si sentono più
berlino vero che le sentiti anche tu
peccato che non puoi parlare altrimenti
lo confermerebbe anche lui
uffa perché non mi credi ma sarà stato
solo il vento figura di io ritorno a
cucinare a dopo l'italia non mi crede
mai quando gli dico che c'è qualcosa di
strano in casa voi li avete sentiti vero
il mio unico testimone e merlino
ma berlino purtroppo non può parlare
e qui vi sentite vitale dove è andato
vitale 67 ora si sentono set i no non
credo siano bassi sembra che ci sia
qualcosa ma non mi sembrano passi di una
persona sei ti puoi bere controllare per
favore tanto tu non hai paura dice
carone niente quindi vai tu a
controllare andrò a controllare io
allora ok io ti aspetto
anzi no ti accompagniamo li vedo anch'io
che cosa succede però non vengo con te
perché
mai visto ma non ai miei più po di paura
di salire da sopra al buio mano sta
accendendo la luce
stai attento mi raccomando tutto buio da
sopra nessuno
piace o niente della mia ombra natale
pericoloso che non andare da berlino per
il marito a ok che c'è che cos'è che
cos'è
niente precedente era solo uno scherzo
ma non è niente non ti preoccupare vera
berlino che non è niente è seduto deve
essere stygia real corto e va bene ne
tornò in camera
gli sono sicuro di sé risentite che
avete sentiti anche poi vero
meglio non pensarci più all'ora ma
vitale dove è finito perché non ritorno
berlino
marino vitale aiko marina dove benito
vitale vitale buono vitale questa
giornata sopra qualcosa hanno catturato
vitale d'italia dove sei ma guarda che
ti vedo break di questo non ti ha
beccato bene allora sorridere smettila
di gelo che l'ho sentito dei passi sopra
la loro ambiente tranquillo
berlino il mio testimone va beh fa
niente allora farò finta di non averli
sentiti nuovamente merlino li senti
anche tu
ora basta non chiamo più vitale
controllerò io da sola visto che lui non
mi crede ho avuto un'idea manico di
scopa busserò anch'io sul tetto così
vediamo se riusciamo a comunicare con
chiunque sia al piano di sopra però di
non farlo arrabbiare
proviamo
[Musica]
i passi si sono fermati sentite quindi
vuol dire che mi ha sentito da qua sotto
però perché si è fermato provo a bussare
di nuovo
[Musica]
berlino previsto anche tu c'è nessuno
chi c'è laggiù vita reditu vitale se mi
stai facendo un'altra scherzo giuro che
ti sbatto questo manico di scopa in
testa c'è solo un modo per scoprire cose
o chi è
devo andare io al piano di sopra non mi
fido di quello che dice vitale poi dov'è
finito vitale
mi porterò anche quest'arma il manico di
scopa ma dov'è finito vitale e doveri
stavo giù a cucinare ti ho detto ti ho
sentito urlare non è che eri al piano di
sopra per caso ho deciso che andrò io a
controllare che cos'è al piano di sopra
perché continuo a sentire dei passi
anche se tu dici di non sentirli andrò
io da sola a controllare e con berlino
se vorrà venire wow che coraggio il
manico di scopa per che cosa di server
perdiate mentre atomiche correndo
michele uno scherzo tu mi aspetterei
così nel caso che trovo qualcosa che
succede qualcosa sarei ad aiutarmi ok va
bene
berlino ha deciso di venire con me per
fortuna che andiamo
mi raccomando se ti chiamo perché ho
visto qualcosa sta lì subito che mi
raccomando vai piano che ha bisogno di
amia siamo qua al piano di sopra
non è neanche troppo buio comunque non
sento nessun rumore tra nei passi di
berlino
forse c'è qualcosa qua puglia berlino
arriva sei tu che stai facendo questo
amore che poi scappa scappa vitale c'è
qualcosa avevo ragione c'è qualcosa
questo ho visto due occhi spaventano
d'italia subito che quando alla camera
sbrigativo ma non vedo niente
questo e merlino guarda accendi la luce
accendi la luce anche se ho paura che
disturberà la creatura che c'è qua come
sta giocando con un pezzo di corda un
giochino non è a merlino era la sola joe
è passata ma legittimamente raggiunti
scendiamo giù e parliamone meglio è
inutile che stiamo anche loro li hanno
visti vero scrivete glielo voi li avete
visti certi ci andiamo giù e mi spieghi
meglio
ok abbiamo tagli ma che vivo ci
allontana legatari andiamo quindi la
luce per non disturbarlo
mi sento molto meglio non essere più la
sopra
ok adesso spiega che cosa è successo
sono passati due occhi malefici anche
loro li hanno visti anche berlino
forse ho capito che cos'è
bastava dirlo prima no che cos'è non è
che sia poi così difficile sono giusto
gli occhi di natino che al buio
diventano rossi no a me non sembravano
proprio per niente gli occhi di berlino
ma si è così semplice e guardano solo
gli occhi di berlino che con la luce è
diventano rosse a tutto è del tutto
normale che berlino sta cercando di
gestiti non era nei suoi occhi
secondo me ti sta immaginando tutto ed
erano solo gli occhi di berlino comunque
io ritorno cucinare tra poco è pronto da
mangiare e vai pure ti rapisce qualcuno
io mi mangerò tutto quello che ho
preparato mangiare
speriamo che sia come dice lui comunque
i suoni sono spariti quindi lasciamo
perdere per ora non è possibile che ci
sia qualcuno nascosto sopra e poi chissà
da quanto tempo ma probabilmente ha
ragione vitale quei passi che sentivo
erano solo degli uccelli che fanno un
nido sopra e gli occhi saranno stati gli
occhi di merlini hanno fatto riflesso
con la luce sono diventati i russi e
quindi sì sicuramente mi sono immaginata
tutto o ci siamo immaginati tutto almeno
spero
[Musica]